dans l'ancien en 2018 par la nasa le
petit télescope spatial tess le chasseur
d'exoplanètes accompli c'est bien son
travail mais n'avait pas encore capturé
une grosse prise un trophée c'est
maintenant fait une planète de la taille
de la terre située à une distance
raisonnable et surnommé dui 710 tess été
lancé pour ce test a été lancée pour
trouver des petites planètes grosses
comme à terre dans la zone habitable de
des toiles qui sont près de nous et ça
c'est la première de cette catégorie là
c'est une étape importante
kepler l'autre chasseur d'exoplanètes
est au rancart et même si on a découvert
plus de 4000 exoplanètes à peine une
douzaine d'entre elles ont un potentiel
d'abriter la vie donc 12 104 miel s'est
pas beaucoup et unis de plus bien ça va
être très intéressant pour le futur de
l'astronomie pour essayer de
caractériser de vraiment d'apprendre
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans l'atmosphère de
ces planètes le tir à 100 da la terre
they will 700d se trouve une centaine
d'années lumière de la terre
suffisamment après pour être analysé
finement par un instrument terrestre ou
encore par le futur grand télescope
spatial james webb
toujours en construction mais qui
devrait être lancée au printemps 2021
elle fait partie d'un groupe de trois
planètes de taille différente qui embête
une étoile naine mais c'est la suite du
trio qui se trouve à la bonne distance
de son soleil dans la fameuse zone dite
habitable le seul pépin
contrairement la terre elles n'orbitent
pas sur elle-même ils sont autant
rotation synchrone donc comme la leur
donc on va toujours la même face ski
type clark comme on la vit pour évoluer
sur ce genre de planète lyon on aurait
des climats très différents on aura un
côté jour un côté nuit continue et à son
côté où il fait froid avec pas ce moment
un genre de dano où on aurait comme un
lever de soleil perpétuelle ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal